welcome back to New rockstars this is a
big question the show they give you too
much information about where you should
sit when you have lunch in the MCU
cafeteria you got to know which Clique
you belong to and let me tell you I'm
not with the Avengers my name is Jessica
Clements I'm not sitting I'm not sitting
with those narcs you're out of your mind
the the one you know how like there's
clicks and there's version two Avengers
version two yeah absolutely we're good
to go yeah but there's like the narcs
and then they have one little cool one
in the dark and I unfortunately think
that's Captain America uh but my name is
Jessica I'm here okay well I think it's
a cool mark because of Civil War we
everything has to be brought back to
Civil War when you guys are thinking
about the Avengers every time everything
speaking of uh Captain America Chris
Evans here uh Brandon Barrick oh no way
no way yes so flattering so after a year
after you dressed up as Iron Man though
I'm like no he does resemble Tony Stark
I got a lot of Tony energy none of them
are me but lots of the internet dude I
don't know if I want I don't want any of
that I'd rather have his money
that's very true oh my God so we're here
today for a big question what's a big
question today Brandon well I'm glad you
asked Jessica you know we've been
hearing a lot of terms for the different
heroes and villains in the MCU lately
but do they have any actual definitions
is there a true classification system at
work here It All Leads us to this week's
big question what are the differences
between enhanced superhumans Inhumans
mutants and others within the MCU I'm
sorry if you can hear me clapping I'm
trying to golf club because this is a
very fun question and also yeah people
watching are probably like oh maybe it
doesn't matter it does matter we've been
throwing these words around too much
with no no ties we're like we needed to
be set in stone right now and I get a
little sus when my government officials
start using terms for people start
separating them out it's dangerous uh
but let's let's see if we can really
parse out the language being used here
and see if we can come up with some
classifications for are all these people
and I think some of these might work
like Venn diagrams too we'll get into it
but there's you know you can throw some
labels around for different groups uh so
let's talk let's start with the term
enhanced okay we first heard the term
used by cap back in Avengers Age of
Ultron when they encountered Quicksilver
AKA Pietro maximoff outside the hydro
research facility in tacopia he's all
like we got enhanced on the fields I'm
narking I'm narking we got enhanced so
this term was most likely used in place
of the term mutant right because you
have to remember at the time Fox owned
the rights to the Marvel mutants uh but
there was some legal gray area because
some of the mutants had also been
Avengers so there was some joint custody
going on it's how we got two different
quicksilvers at the same time in two
different cinematic universes right but
now Disney owns everything they own them
all they bought it all up uh and they
can slowly start using the terms again
as they see fit but at the time when
like Age of Ultron came out they
couldn't say the word mutant they
couldn't say it so they said enhanced
okay but calling both Pietro and Wanda
maximoff enhanced and eventually some
other characters as well does make a lot
of sense right they're normal humans
whose abilities were enhanced by an
object okay true it's why you could also
it's all it's why you could also refer
to Kamala Khan as enhanced since the
Bengal appeared to give her abilities
right or at least it might have uh
through the powers may have been innate
inside of her the van Gogh enhanced it I
think this is that right this yeah 100
but that is the problem problem I have
with the term is because it's like just
because because technically
um Thor could be an enhanced individual
when he's using a weapon like when he's
using yeah yeah you could say that that
gives him more power uh we don't really
know yet for sure with Miss Marvel right
and also agent Cleary of the dodc
calling her enhanced because he assumes
something has given her those Powers uh
that he saw displayed in the cell phone
video you know we're hearing the term
used by him and maybe he doesn't
understand what her powers are yet and
he's calling everybody enhanced because
in his mind no one's born with powers
they all get them from somewhere else
right which Loki High key very racist he
is problematic the dodc is hella
problematic we already we clearly saw
that with the interrogation and then
just yeah doing horrible things last
week here on big questions for sure
thank you but also I think that's why
the terms of these are all like very
human terms and not come I mean right
any of the people with superpowers
period yeah exactly exactly what do they
want to be called let's ask them let's
ask them but you also have other
Avengers such as Captain America and
Iron Man that you could consider it as
enhanced since Steve Rogers had the
super soldier serum and Tony Stark had
the Iron Man suit both of these objects
enhanced their otherwise regular human
abilities right so I think it's safe to
Define enhanced as a normal human who
has their abilities enhanced by some
external Force I think that's a you
think that's a good definition for
enhanced I think so and also it is what
it is enhanced it's someone that's
enhanced and like your Thor example
right yes the mjolnir might enhance some
of his powers but he has innate Powers
right he was born with that I think the
term enhanced is going to be the Venn
diagram that one that word itself it's
gonna Encompass a lot of things it's
gonna Encompass a lot of people because
I think it is just having a lot
everyone's enhanced technically I mean
yeah well that's why they're Heroes
right that's why they're Heroes yeah
that's true there's a couple and we'll
get into these in our next category but
like people like Natasha Romanoff and
Clint Barton okay Bishop not really
enhanced no because okay so you have to
have the power beforehand if you're just
a nor so like Batman isn't an enhanced
because they're just humans
right right yeah they're just humans
they're just normal humans that can
fight very well or just have eagle eyes
yeah and Tony Stark being like a super
genius that does not make him enhanced
but building the Iron Man suit yes makes
him enhanced because now he has a power
well now let's talk about superhumans
okay this term seems to be relatively
new to the MCU uh I couldn't find like
uh being used uh anywhere in the movies
before end game right uh there's been
descriptions of individuals having
superhuman strength they said that uh in
Black Panther uh but in the trailer for
She-Hulk we have a government official
classifying the individuals as
superhuman uh he's saying like we're
starting a superhuman law division right
so what do we think this means exactly I
would think it applies to any human that
exhibits Superior strength speed
reflexes healing ability Etc basically a
human Plus
foreign
if you have superhuman strength or
superhuman speed it means that your
strength or your speed is more than
beyond what a normal human is capable of
doing I think I can't wait for the
person in the MCU to be like a superhero
a superhuman like lawyer firm and
they're like you say soup for her and
it's like no super super human and
someone's like I thought you said soup
I'm not going in there I thought you
served soup here where's my soup hell is
this I don't have a law I don't need a
law I need some soup I need some soup
I need some business I feel like that's
the confusion in the boys people are
constantly like soup soup if no one no
one says tomato bisque nobody says a
tomato where's the bisque they turn them
into tomato bisque oh
God let me tell you about it check into
the boys underground every Friday
[Laughter]
uh yeah no that makes sense that makes
sense I think they're just yeah
superhumans are just yeah yes keep going
continue I agree they're they're humans
plus right so there's probably some
overlap between enhanced and superhuman
like we were talking about for example
you have Steve Rogers is an enhanced
individual that you would also consider
superhuman but not all of our heroes are
superhuman and we talked about them
earlier but both Natasha Romanoff and
Clinton Barton would be considered more
Peak human right they're at the very top
of the abilities of a human but they're
not going Beyond what's possible yeah
they're Peak human
yeah I will never be a peak human
performing at the peak of my abilities
just average please thank you so much
and someone like Thor should not be
considered superhuman
because he's not human exactly he has
superhuman abilities but that's only
like a term of measurement like for
example you could say a car has 200
horsepower but it's not a super horse
right it's still a car we're just
measuring its speed by horsepower which
is insane great old Jerry Seinfeld bit
about why are we still using the term
horsepower it's just mean to horses they
can't compete uh it's not fair but
that's that's the measurement we had at
the time when cars came around so we're
like oh that car's like two horsepower
it's like two horses uh but it's not a
super horse it's not yeah it's not a
super horse Thor is an alien god if
anything he's super Asgardian not
superhuman right he's stronger than your
standard ass Guardian who are already
strong uh and he has superhuman strength
but he's not a superhuman that Thor
ain't no super human that ain't no human
I've never seen a human like that
literally I ain't never seen such a
beautiful man it's a golden hair
and Hercules the Disney movie is when he
knocks over all of the like the podiums
and someone's like he's too dangerous to
be around normal people
that's that's Thor with the humans just
like Hercules pretty much shouldn't be
around normal people because he's not a
normal person he's a God no he's
breaking coffee cups at the diner all
the time another
he's problematic yeah he is but I love
him I love him I love them okay Jessica
so we mentioned Miss Marvel earlier who
in the comics is technically an inhuman
so let's get into Inhumans uh and we're
not far enough in the show yet to
confirm if the mcu's Kamala Khan is in
fact an inhuman we haven't gotten that
far we're still watching the show when
we're recording this but we did have
Black Bolt appear in the Multiverse of
Madness showing that there are in fact
Inhumans within the broader universes of
the MCU right outside of the 616 there's
definitely Inhumans and there was also
maybe an Inhumans TV show at some point
but I don't really remember Jessica I
can't recall ever see wait like uh like
I don't think there wasn't a humans TV
show there was we don't like to talk
about it why don't we like to talk about
it because it's not a good show what
show okay wait are we thinking about two
different shows what are you saying
there was a TV show called Inhumans on
ABC I didn't not watch that [ __ ] show
okay never mind I am and I am sure I
didn't watch the show for some reason
for a minute I thought you were talking
about either Legion or you're talking
about
um 97 97. I'll talk about Legion all the
time and I'll talk about X-Men 97 as
soon as it comes out talk about in
humans no I didn't know that TV show but
it does not exist and within x uh MCU
616 it's way out there somewhere go
watch it if you're feeling no don't but
I don't even know I watched the trailer
and was like I don't need to watch it
it's the same actor who plays Black Bolt
they did bring him into Multiverse of
Madness but there's a there's a
possibility that they are going to bring
them into the 616 MCU so we're going to
include them on this list okay and
humans are known scientifically as in
homo supremacists uh and what they are
are they're altered human beings that
came about as a result of experiments
committed on prehistoric humans by the
cree our good friends decree by using a
process known as Terror Genesis and a
human can unlock the augmentation within
their DNA a to activate their abilities
Terra Genesis uses the myths from
teragen crystals which were also created
by the cree technology and because of
their Advanced genetics and humans tend
to live longer about 150 years
now why did the cree makes it making
humans you ask well the cree were
performing these experiments on
prehistoric humans thousands of years
ago in an attempt to build a weapon to
use in their mini Wars that they just
love having however they got spooked
when the Supreme intelligence had a
prophecy that warned that in humans
would eventually take down the cree so
they abandoned their experiments they
left them on Earth thinking they would
just die out in this ancient Earth but
they didn't they lived on and they
formed their own secret hidden society
and they have cute little ceremonies
where they do Terra Genesis and they're
like oh look at your powers you could
have the powers without the Terra
Genesis but it's it helps unlock them
basically it's like a big ceremony for
them now we don't know how much the
inhuman species will play a role in the
616 MCU but if they are thinking of
introducing them fully we could hear the
term inhuman much more often and the way
things are going on Miss Marvel I feel
like they might be leaning towards this
storyline and they easily could just
drop it and that could be the opening
door to like secret Invasion it could be
not the opening door but like this is a
big deal and the career we're gonna see
the cree again in secret Invasion so
it's like
yeah I mean honestly
I thought when they bought when Disney
bought the rights to the mutants back I
thought for sure like oh they'll never
touch Inhumans ever again because like
yes the Inhumans were invented like in
the 70s but they weren't very popular in
Marvel Comics but during the time when
like Disney and Marvel didn't own the
film rights to the mutants the comic
book stopped doing the mutants and they
got rid of a lot of mutants and they
stopped making New Mutants yeah and they
kind of focused on doing Inhumans
instead which are very there's very
there's big similarities between
Inhumans and mutants we'll get into
mutants here in a second but I thought
they would never really bring them into
the MCU but it seems like with Kamala
Khan they're trying to like maybe go
down that storyline now she didn't do a
terrigen Mist thing right the Bengal is
not Terra Genesis uh but like they like
I said if humans have the power like
inside of them already and it and a lot
of times it gets unlocked through Terror
Genesis if this bangle is doing some
sort of weird you know version of Terror
Genesis we might find that out I don't
know
it's not saying that there couldn't be a
Cree there that still has the terrigen
mist and can release right exactly um
Jessica she found her powers first
doesn't mean later on in the episode
that they can like still use it to
unleash this unlock even more Powers
Yeah yeah and that and you're right
Jessica that could be when she
transitions from this like hard light to
actually like in beginning herself yeah
I think and not using the light right
mutants you said mutants yeah let's talk
about immunes Jessica now this is the
classification we are all very
impatiently waiting for in the MCU we
want the mutants baby Newton's also
known as homo Superior are humans with
mutations caused by X genes in their DNA
most mutations manifest around the age
of puberty usually tied to some tragic
or traumatic event uh but some some
mutants do have power straight from
birth which could be very problematic
oh my God this is all based on the
comics of course as we haven't confirmed
mutants within the 616 MTU though though
there were hints that Wanda and perhaps
even Pietro had powers before their
exposure to the Mind Stone If you recall
these hints came from the flashback and
wand division when the Stark bomb
crashes into the maximoff house and
doesn't explode Pietro may have saved
Wanda in that initial crash by moving at
super speed to like pull her away he
didn't even know he was doing it right
while Wanda we know for sure definitely
prevented the bomb from exploding with
her chaos magic right Agatha Harkness
kind of confirmed that now
are they going to say her chaos magic is
a mutation I don't know we'll we'll have
to see about that but
I assume that however we have confirmed
mutants in the 616 MCU their biology
will still be tied to the X Gene because
that's like super important for mutants
yeah I think I I don't know if they're
going to say like mutants have always
been there we just haven't talked about
them I think that they might bring all
the mutants in From Another Universe
that's getting destroyed I don't know
how they're going to do it I mean a lot
of times during one division right
Jessica we thought that like the hex
itself was going to activate all the
mutants like it was gonna explode and
send all this energy out throughout the
world and just turn on people's ex genes
like out of nowhere I think they're
going to bring I was like thinking
they'll bring them from a different
universe that would be so abrupt and so
chaotic to be like who opens all these
portals and allows them all in from
different Universe uh unless right
I don't know by the way that's up to
Kevin feig you can't wait for him to
decide
he's laying awake at night like how am I
gonna do this
the fans are constantly
awake there's someone calling his night
his house every night just breathing
being like Mutant
Ninja
how'd you get my phone number I gotta
change it every goddamn minute do you
like mutant mutant movies Kevin feige
what's your favorite Newton movie
stop calling me
I would go insane if I was Kevin feige I
would literally slowly lose my mind and
my brain would I would have retired by
now
I'd be like you can have anybody else
can have it I'm done
so mutants we can certainly classify
some of them as superhuman right
depending on their mutation they have
like super human strength speed whatever
uh and there is evidence from the comics
that mutants can also be exposed to the
Terra Genesis process uh that the in
humans go through but there are usually
very bad results for the mutants when
that happened it usually kills a mutant
so uh don't do that don't do it guys
okay so one more category I want to talk
about is aliens and that seems really
easy right because like anyone who's not
from Earth is an alien boom bada boom
got it and that would be like a ton of
characters within the MCU but what does
that mean about the gods Jessica should
we classify Gods as aliens do you think
like all God ads are aliens like I think
Thor is for sure right Thor's an alien
Odin's an alien yeah well if Thor's
being referred to an alien why couldn't
the rest of them be referred to as
aliens
right because they're they're basically
a lot of the gods are just aliens who
live on like another planet or a
different dimension and like visit Earth
and our big dumb dumb idiot ancestors
were like these are Gods because they
didn't understand the concept of other
worlds and all that stuff right what do
we think about like the Egyptian gods
though should we consider them aliens
it's such a hard question
uh so I Googled it I was
like
a bit I guess for me it's like
have they touched down on Earth because
that would make them pour into Earth
which makes them aliens right
and then well I will say like with the
Egyptian gods in the comics they were
created by they were all created by Adam
uh who was like created by one of the
Elder Gods I forget which one I think
guys
no it's like atum atom right she creates
atom to help fight to kill all the
dinosaurs one which was kind of messed
up uh because like set set who was an
elder god uh was like ruling the planet
with Dinosaurs so she creates Adam to
help kill all these things uh and then
Adam basically goes off to the celestial
halopolis and creates all the other
Egyptian gods So Adam was maybe like
could could be considered like
superhuman Earthling who then goes away
and then becomes an alien I don't know
or like creates a bunch of aliens but I
think most of like those like gods are
aliens but this brings up like the big G
Gods right Jessica
yeah
Galactus The Watcher Celeste Jewels I
don't consider them aliens I consider
them like Gods I guess the watch they
were a race of aliens right well I guess
I guess they could be both I can't say
people
[Music]
the way to think about it is like God's
is a very human term yeah that's true
that's true
it's a very Planet level term right
because Gore is using the term God but
like if most gods are just aliens from
other planets or Dimensions uh and then
you have that that that's what they are
and then you have like the big G Gods
like Infinity they're like outside of
the universe almost in like a different
way like The Watcher he comes from a
race of aliens but they're super
Advanced alien species so much Advanced
that I think you could call them big G
Gods because they're beyond the realm of
like normal Humanity I also want to
reiterate what I said before these terms
were created by the human beings not by
everybody who we're calling aliens and
who we're calling Gods except for the
gods of guys
but
um we came up with these terms so
there's gonna be so many times that they
again then diagram themselves or cross
streams because it's like
phrase to use because it makes sure no
we can use it was used in Ghostbusters
to much much success okay there you go
we got streams that one's a really hard
question
I personally can answer
was aliens
because I still call them all aliens
because they're all still physical
beings and most of them are just aliens
they're just aliens they're just aliens
they're creatures somewhere else yeah
just they're not Gods to me I'm not
they're not again
my God oh my God the celestial something
else entirely no the Watchers if I was
you guys are so like I'm not an MCU
because if I got you that I would just
be picking my gods based off which one
was the coolest yeah and I would
probably choose the Watcher if I found
out the Watchers existed I'd be like
that's my God that's my God that's my
God right always watching never okay
empty that's my God mtnj Washington my
gods okay but yeah I digress that's a
hard question that's so freaking hard
yeah but those are our classifications
Jessica like I think those that I think
we did a good job kind of parsing them
out uh and like we said there's a lot of
Venn diagram a lot of cross streams uh
you can have multiple labels as a hero
in the MCU but hopefully this helps uh
kind of put some of them into categories
you know what you should do and I don't
know if this is a big question or just a
tick tock but you should go through like
all of
all of the showed up in MCU and classify
them as superhuman alien uh inhuman
mutant just because they do cross-stream
so often that it's like yeah if you give
me a list they're all gonna be the same
like Thor is going to be true everyone
has at least two classifications if
you're one or a loser you're a hella
Lena if you're just one you only got one
classification you suck you suck hey
I was mainly thinking I love him to
death but I was like Bucky
you're just just what you just got that
extra no I guess Bucky has a lot going
on
he's super human and he's seriously yeah
he's two God dang it no it is just
Captain America he's got an arm now too
that's definitely enhanced that's what I
was saying I was like yeah he's inhuman
because the arm and that's like wakanda
Tech too so it's like that alone by
itself is enough and that you got him
getting Juiced up and being a sniper
agent would you yeah so okay sorry to go
back really quick
people like when I when you were talking
about
um super Inhumans or super humans I was
thinking enhanced would have to be like
it would have to be technology is the
separation between the two or like the
right like yeah Bucky who's superhuman
but the bionic arm is the enhanced part
but people like uh uh Captain America we
wouldn't call enhance with the shield
because it's just a shield it's not like
well no you wouldn't call him enhanced
because of the shield you would call
them enhanced because of the super
soldier serum
enhanced him and made him a super human
like Batman right he's only Ant-Man
would only be enhanced because he wears
a suit which gives him the ability this
is so fun I actually like putting these
people in their categories because it
also shows you who should be on your
team and who shouldn't be on your team
but thank you Brandon be sure to head to
newrockstarsmerch.com to grab our newest
latest Obsession shirt Cosmic Daydream
this shirt inspired by Miss Marvel and
designed partially by Philip Molina is a
limited edition and won't last long and
when you buy the latest Obsession shirt
you unlock the opportunity to get a
custom shout out on inside marble on our
Miss Marvel after show hosted by uh Papa
Eric Voss and papa Mt check out all our
awesome merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com and before we dive
into our buy size questions next some
words from the people to help us bring
the question to you bomba's mission is
simple make the most comfortable clothes
ever and match every item sold with an
equal item donated So when you buy
bombas you are also giving to someone in
need bombas designed their socks shirts
and underwear to be the clothes you
can't wait to put on every day
everything they make is soft seamless
tagless and has a cozy feel they come in
tons of options like comfy performance
Styles made with sweat wicking Yarns
which means your feet stay cool while
the rest of you works up a sweat bombas
don't show socks are designed for
Comfort while being specially engineered
to never fall down so let your ankles be
free to soak up the sunlight I love
bomba socks I'm wearing a pair right now
I love their ankle socks all the time
they look great no show on my shoes they
look my ankles stay nice and sunny and
plus their socks like never slip down
they're never like a lot of ankle socks
I feel like they slip off so easily
bombas never do that they're the best
socks I love them they're so great but
bombas also makes t-shirts with
thoughtful design features like
invisible seams soft fabrics and the
perfect weight so they hang just right
on your body bomba's underwear is so
breathable and fits so well it feels
like you're wearing nothing at all in a
good way in a way you won't get in
trouble for and did you know that socks
underwear and t-shirts are the three
most requested clothing items at
homeless shelters that's why bombas
donates one for every item you buy so
far Baba's customers like you have
helped donate over 50 million items of
essential clothing and that's awesome go
to bombas.com bigquestion and get 20 off
your first purchase that's
b-o-m-b-a-s.com slash big question for
20 off bombas.com big question and now
it's on to our bite-sized question
that's not bite-sized you're beating the
hell out of that they're little bites
it's in a moose boosh being passed
around and a moose boosh is that what
the thing in Pac-Man eats the little
balls because that's what it looked like
you were straight up munching on that
okay
the back the tanks work in the Star Wars
Universe how do you rent one also I need
to know for a friend
I need a I need a back to tank I mean
we're all familiar with one of the most
OP devices in the Star Wars universe and
I ain't talking lightsabers I'm talking
about that back to tank it's the tubular
machine filled with back to fluid that
appears to heal everything from
hypothermia and wild animal trauma to
being burned alive by your teacher but
how does it work you might ask uh well
it's all about the bacta the tank itself
doesn't do much other than to help hold
the back to uh in place so that you can
put it all over your body and it seems
that you need to be fully submerged in
order for the back to to do its job
though we have seen back to Patches used
in Clone Wars like just a little patch
of bacta and there were instances of
like back to being injected directly but
for the most part you got to be totally
submerged uh with a little breather
which I think is insane and if I woke up
and inside of that thing I would freak
out I can't believe they do that to
people who have been traumatized awful
uh so yeah it is all about the back to
fluid itself but what is back to fluid
well it's a liquid created by the
viratics also known as typherians from
the planet of typhera they're these
large praying mantis looking species
very frightening looking but man the
back is great they invented back to over
4 000 years before the Battle of Yavin
and bacta could only be made on typhera
and that's because the the resources
that were needed to make it were
abundant on that planet
bhakta consists of red alasi which is a
bacterium found from fungus that grow in
typhera and cavum which is uh secreted
from the glance of the viratics but
thankfully it can also be made
synthetically but the OG stuff like came
out of their bodies they mixed these two
things uh with the viscous fluid known
as ambori and boom you got yourself some
delicious bhakta back to replaced the
previously used culto healing juice
which was just some dumb ocean water
from the planet of Madan fact is way
cooler it comes from bug juice awesome
so once you're submerged in the back to
tank the bacterial particles in the
bacta promote rapid tissue growth and
prevent scarring awesome at one point
the companies of the zalton corporation
and the Zucker Corporation both made
bacta but once the emperor took over he
shot that down the Empire controlled who
supplied uh all the bacta and they only
allowed it to be made on typhera and
then they would stockpile it on best
spin with our good buddy Lando calritian
the rebels actually had a very limited
supply of bacta it was hard to get so it
was real nice of them to use it on our
boy Luke though he did blow up the Death
Star he's the MVP of the rebellion of
course she's going to put that man in a
back to tank use all the back that you
got on this guy let the other ones die
that's what a back to tank is it's
mainly all about the back to juice uh
it's I think it's a little op but you
gotta have it it's important way to go
Star Wars way to go stop
our second bite-sized question
what are some of the weirdest things
made with the Green Lantern ring there
have been some strange things made with
the Green Lantern ring uh and a lot of
them came from Kyle Raynor uh he's made
a giant teddy bear that he used to fight
somebody which is hilarious and funny uh
he also made a giant firefighter to put
out like a building that was on fire
just made like a giant instead of just
like making the water up here he he made
a giant firefighter with a hose to spray
down the building which I think is funny
he also our boy Kyle Reiner made a giant
pirate ship to fly the Justice League
through space uh instead of just making
a spaceship he made like a pirate ship
it had like winches on it it was a
little much yeah our good buddy when is
the Green Lantern not too much he is so
extra with winning using his Green
Lantern ring well I've learned that Kyle
Rayner really went extra I guess the
writers during his his period as Green
Lantern had a lot of fun uh but our good
buddy Hal Jordan he's done some weird
stuff too uh the the craziest thing when
he was having a little mental breakdown
after Coast City was destroyed uh he
basically recreated the whole city and
everyone that lived in it and went and
had like crazy conversations with them
while while he was working through some
of his own trauma so that was like a
little intense like remaking a whole
city that had been destroyed Hal Jordan
also made a super painkiller pill when
he was trapped in a pain-inducing stasis
field he made like he's like I'm gonna
make myself a painkiller well it was
like oh you should just do that with
that great I hate this I hate this world
like the Green Lantern just like going
to a rave and passing out MDMA that he's
making with his green ring oh yeah he
could be the only drug dealer yeah right
and then I got a uh another a couple
crazy ones from our boy Kyle Rainer
again uh he made Kryptonite once after
Martian Manhunter kind of stole the
recipe from Superman's mind he's like
boom I made some Kryptonite stay back
[ __ ] uh and then finally the weirdest
thing and probably the most intense
thing uh Kyle Rayner made a functioning
electric chair uh he used this against
Major Force uh now Major Force was the
villain who put Kyle rainer's girlfriend
inside of a refrigerator which was a
very pivotal moment in comics uh for
pointing out that uh women are often
treated very poorly in comics and used
as as uh very traumatic devices uh and
not treated as equally Fair as the men
in comics uh so yeah that was a moment
you know it is what it is but it's funny
they think that tied to that story you
have the Green Lantern go and make an
electric chair he puts Major Force in it
he doesn't wind up killing him with it
but he definitely like shocks him a
bunch of times it's just very intense
and very like uh I'm gonna think of a
very elaborate way to use this ring to
hurt you so a bit much a bit much the
Green Lantern also I think it was in
Justice League War where he if you guys
are like the Green Lantern is too wild I
need him to be toned down go to Justice
League War where Batman is so smooth
that he steals his ring it's a he
literally the Green Lantern's like
um you're just a man in a suit why are
you even fighting with us and he's
constantly ragging on Batman and he's
like you're just a man in a suit and
then finally Batman like smoothly takes
his ring and he turns back into his
normal self and Batman's like oh so
you're also just a man
did health and it's so funny it's so
good and then it dies pretty fast so
it's whatever
um yeah he's a yeah those mother
well he's enhance that one's just a
superhuman
yeah man okay time uh going to another
man that's a little bad and problematic
a box of script s
oh box of scraps I'm talking about the
guys
what's the essence name that plays box
of scraps
um
Jeff Bridges I always want to call him
Russell Russell crowd no I know the
difference of those two I think it's
because when they were young I'm sure
they were both auditioning for the same
[ __ ] so I'm constantly getting Kurt
Russell and Jeff Bridge's mixed up but
once the dude and one's big trouble
little China okay okay if you had the
phone
yeah I've been growing up I always
wanted to be like a mutant but I I
that's really risky really rolling the
dice because you could get a really
strange mutation I wouldn't even want
one of the ones we listed I just want
like Peak human I just want to be a peak
human uh like like Hawkeyes
yeah yeah but not like I don't want to
be a superhuman where people are like
relying on me and I'm getting like
tested on by the government I just want
to be a peak human compete in the
Olympics get a couple sponsorships
that's all I need that's all I need I
would love to be a superhuman clearly oh
okay that'd be super cool but I feel
like I
want that strength but I feel like I
would never have that opportunity so
then I'm thinking I'd probably just be
an enhanced individual because I want to
be someone that's smart enough to create
my own technology for myself like uh
Peter Parker
um yeah another enhanced individual in
some universes uh enhanced because well
he got bit by a spider which enhanced
his abilities but now he's definitely
superhuman yeah for sure well where's
our and we're talking 616 Peter Parker
if we're talking like you're talking 616
yeah if we're talking uh Oscar Isaac and
across the spider verse he's definitely
just enhanced he just has a bunch of
mechanical weapons he's just using Tech
yeah he's just using Tech at the end of
the day sadly I feel like I just be an
alien and then I'd be an alien on
another world that does normal Jessica
things so it wouldn't even be I love the
cool kind of alien like a Cree that's
like I have all this technology I'd be
making toast
on another planet not working because we
don't have to work on that planet you
see we're more advanced in some ways to
be Japan would be so sick though except
for the terrigen Mystic I would hate to
be like a mutant and then be like yeah
people are constantly trying to kill me
with this this ball of part of the
terrorism
and it kills me it literally kills me
I'm like this is great cool all right
it's cool but you gotta hope you get a
good power and not a bad power well
that's what I would like about the munes
it's like Sky High I like that like
people getting different powers like the
boys when they take care of the compound
B it it's different for each one so I'm
like yeah I would love to know what mine
would be but it would have to be one I
wouldn't want to be like Mystique like I
would not want to be Mystique that would
that would be the one that turns into a
bird a giant bird like that's not a good
one to permanently change don't I don't
want that in my life I don't want to
permanently be like walking around at
first you're like oh man I have these
big hands and these big feet I don't
like that and next time you know your
blue Fury you're like oh this is way
worse yeah I'd want to just be Rogue and
kill people I'd be a villain
I would absolutely that's understood
you guys weren't villain in this
scenario not see me because you guys
would all be dead I'd be like
um
did Brandon eat my food excuse me excuse
me
real quick oh you did you're dead you're
dead and that is it for a big question
but I do also want to see in the
comments you guys can tweet at us too
or more realistically what do you see
yourself as
who do you see it on the inside who do
you yeah who are you on the inside if
you're in stem you're automatically
enhanced because congratulations you can
make anything and you would use that
brain for intelligence I'm not
intelligent I went to a liberal arts
school I majored in Puppeteer theater
thank you Brandon you're selling
Puppeteer theater her thank you Brandon
for joining me for this episode uh
follow him at granted Barrick follow me
at Lulu underscore Clements follow new
rockstars here on YouTube and all social
media platforms make sure to hit that
notification Bell and if you've got some
big questions of your own share them on
the new Rockstar's Discord server uh
only catch you have to be over 18.
doesn't seem like that bad of a deal
um click the link for the new rockstars
Discord in the description below uh like
subscribe follow and uh go be a mutant
yeah go go go crawling
thank you
[Music]